a groundbreaking law in California will
give 40 million people the strongest
internet privacy rights in US history it
takes effect tomorrow many tech
companies collect personal information
including birthdays email addresses and
users interest without ever asking
permission and they earn big money
selling it well starting tomorrow
Californians will actually be able to
limit what happens when their
information is collected John Blackstone
shows us how the new law could affect
all Americans
the familiar login page on many websites
that asks for personal information will
have something new on it beginning in
the new year at least if it's someone in
California who was logging in one of the
requirements of the California law is on
the home page of your site that you
actually display a button that says do
not sell my data Chris Babel CEO of data
privacy company trust Ark says consumers
in California will have broad new
control over data collected above 3 as a
consumer I can come and ask you for my
information I could ask you to delete
that information such that you purge it
and you tell the people you've shared it
with to purge or finally I could ask you
to not sell it to other parties and just
kind of keep it to yourself many in the
tech industry whose business models
often depend on the collection of
consumer data fought hard to stop the
California Consumer Protection Act from
becoming law this is a story only in
America you know one person being able
to take on an industry Alister McTaggart
was determined to win new protections
for consumers by lobbying in the state
capitol and funding a campaign to
collect signatures for a ballot measure
it is an extraordinary story mostly
about America and the ability to take on
the world's most profitable most
powerful industry right now and be able
to come up with meaningful reforms
fortunately you had the money to do it
red this cost you what more than three
million dollars mm-hmm you know I've
been super fortunate in in my life and I
do believe you have a duty to try to
make the world better McTaggart a San
Francisco area commercial real estate
developer got involved after learning
just how closely big Internet companies
are tracking us it makes everything more
valuable they know kind of everything
about everybody the companies tell us
this is good for
that it helps them provide us services I
don't like you I've never encountered a
real-life human being who comes to me
there's my big problem I don't get
enough relevant ads California's
Attorney General is responsible for
enforcing the law and companies may
dispute its requirements Facebook says
its current privacy rules already comply
with the new law including its ban on
selling user data the company says it
supports the new legislation these are
remarkable companies that have done
remarkable things I'm not at all let's
burn the house down kind of a person but
I do think that capitalism needs some
rules some rules of the road and the
rule should be that we the people have
power over our own information for now
the new protections apply only in
California but the state has 12 percent
of the u.s. population and a few
companies including Microsoft have said
they will extend the same rights to all
Americans for CBS this morning John
Blackstone San Francisco let's see if
the federal government takes some cues
from California's right
you